[Music]
and like-minded news submitted by fans
since 2006 oh but wait we started in
2007 buddy oh wait well we had channels
in 2006 so he might even be old school
old school mm-hmm yeah personal channels
before we did jks oh damn you guys
should have been
chitta done way better
researchers believe brain scans can
predict who you're likely to be friends
with I'll for real
I believe that hmm brain scan yeah
you're this type of person and he should
be friends with that type of person
gotta fill in the blank okay so if you
if even if you get a brain scan and you
think that this is what you're locked in
with in 10 years when your brain changes
you need a whole new set of friends if
your friends don't grow with you I am
tired of making new friends I like this
here yeah but what if you go oh you
don't and you're like my friends are
immature no I doubt that's ever gonna
happen
that's all it's our friends are immature
I mean holy [ __ ] what's what's more
immature than us I'm not even try pay my
bills
no that's respects co-payments dude we
have it so easy yeah come on yeah so
researchers are saying that they believe
they can predict who you're more likely
to be friends with like what Bart was
saying they scan your brain and then
they'll scan other people's brains and
they'll say oh okay I can tell that you
would be friends with this person
because they're like-minded how they
know that because of the frequency our
brain operates in it's like we are on
the same wavelength I know yeah they
have similar neural activity mmm so
we're on the same frequency EQ baby so
it's like the pattern like a boy
activated yeah so like if you're
consuming a TV show or a movie depending
on the brain activity that they see in
the brain scans and then like if someone
else has a similar activity does you'll
most likely to be friends it makes a lot
of sense cuz I you could we can all
receive the same information you know
some people that are immediately
believing in it some people get
emotionally aroused with
there may be other starts firing and
then some people are very very logically
minded I think those logically people if
I want to talk and then the most of
people want to talk and stuff like that
so
so what are we there yeah what are we
we're not all that similar we're gonna
see what that different no yeah no I was
gonna say that but I'm like yes true
we're not that similar but I guess thank
you I mean we're similar enough in the
world but of course we're all still
individuals I I know the common
denominator of these events know we are
where we are no bullshitter
none of us take the [ __ ] [ __ ]
mean too deep right now I know
no no but you are not no no I don't
think you understand what I'm talking
about so we are all like we go for the
truth yeah I mean like you know you're
you're not a fraud yeah there's nothing
about you that is fraudulent none of us
are fraudulent and we can't hang out
with people that better like that's fair
that's a lot of fun right right right
right
so we might come from different walks of
life that's why we can't hang with most
tubers yep cuz they're fraudulent
[ __ ] that chiasm
mmm to catch you up in too deep is what
we call tips life because past lectures
oh yeah yet she does have to say no now
she's a lot better yeah she can't yeah
that's almost sometimes I push her
around just for fun but then when she
stands up I go you go TIFF and that is
she's in too deep because she's had past
relationships with romantic
relationships or just platonic
relationships where she just gets taken
advantage of situations she's just not
happy in that situation but she doesn't
know how to get out of it cuz she's too
nice she's capacitive what but that's
like what what's like just like you're
like always being mindful of somebody
else's feelings it just looks like it
sucks I know it sucks I'm really other
people first so it I feel like I lose a
sense of myself because I'm always
catering to other people when have you
ever cared to other people I'm trying to
figure that out right now too can you
give me an example I poured out your
drink before you I poured it out to
myself that's just being considerate
yeah
I rest my case all right okay yes i'm
david backfires on me too like i
considered too much the point where like
it comes off you know those people or
like let's say you go to a restaurant
and you have like the waitress that
interview Mike two nights to the point
where it's like annoying where she's
like let's figure this is the type of
[ __ ] where it's like you go on
somebody's Instagram and it says like or
their dating profile and it's like I
wear my heart on my sleeve and I know it
[ __ ] and like all this [ __ ] where it's
like I'm such a good person thing I
don't like that stuff the one that
drives me crazy speaking of Instagram
profiles is when they say like Jesus
lover but they're the first people
leaving hate on your [ __ ] pictures
and so true they have like a Jesus like
John 3:16 and in a p.m. you like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] that one still kind of
makes sense a little bit but when they
write [ __ ] like you're [ __ ] you're so
[ __ ] ugly and stupid or whatever it's
likely but it's even I bet you know the
worst part is this is like you know it's
like the Instagram post Christ first mm
know if it was Christ first you would
not have an Instagram right dick first
yeah dick first
Christ last but people who have to talk
about how great they are
that bothers me like the [ __ ] who people
who are like I would die for my friend
I'd jump in front of a [ __ ] boy for
my family you would not die for your
friend shut the [ __ ] you can't say this
[ __ ] man this shit's like I would jump
in front of a train for you see exactly
how could you say it damn I would have
done it for you though what my feelings
are hurt so let's continue let's see how
do you know that song that kind of [ __ ]
I don't know the romanticism
anticipation of eronel you know I did
think about this scenario though let's
say I wonder what will happen let's say
like for example uh Joe right there's a
car coming at both these two at the same
time I running away
I love it I thought you were gonna go
through him automatically finish okay so
if they're right here and then they
don't they don't see it though that
person can hear the only thing you can
do is save one of them instinctually
you're not gonna think about who you
care about more you're gonna have to
just save one of them
oh it's whoever is likely to survive no
no but for real though it's if if a car
is coming right
and it's like for sure gonna kill Bart
but if I yell and then Jill could jump
out the way of course it's gonna be I
think for me it's whoever has the higher
percentage of survive I love the idea
that that they have to hear their name
called individuals I know they're gonna
be safe hey hey yeah it's like I didn't
hear my name that's the way I think he's
gonna kill us if he says our name is cuz
we're like now he has our attention so
we don't even know what the [ __ ]
happening back here that's [ __ ] up no
but when so this is the thing when
people call for like attention then
it'll be like ah like I think that's the
worst thing you could do because they'll
be like what you gotta say jump right
that's what I said it was like oh [ __ ]
left just a car yeah does a car car car
car sometimes it doesn't work though
like a basketball ball let me go yeah
that's so true man because before it
would just hit the back of your head and
now it just crushed your nose yeah but
you can't tell me when it's sports busy
copal me immediately do this thing well
I just do that cuz I just get hit in the
head a lot so yeah well so instead of
like eHarmony now they could do brain
harmony and then you could get your
brain scanned and you can see who you
kind of match so [ __ ] dumb no you
don't know how to make friends yet come
on oh yeah like it's it's like that
black mirror episode where they had the
couple people up that way too
dude it's like a strategy
astrology is like oh you're a what
you're a Taurus well I'm a Virgo so
that's an ethic and we're not gonna jive
it's like what it takes the fart out of
making friends and this yes because the
obstacles and challenges is what makes
it fun yeah what are your guys's science
I'm a Scorpio Libra is that does it does
that flow right that was it make that
work Nicki's the astrologist here oh
yeah yes she's Miss moonstones stuff
collecting it at a [ __ ] like 2:00
a.m. in the morning she's gonna wear no
shoes pretty soon watch out for that I
know he's gotta walk around with a
dashiki and like pearls and like dude
she's my sick ho my dude I'm just
waiting for the next thing she'll be
wearing her dad's is a [ __ ] scarf no
shoes perfect content Bryan do you have
no idea I know this like she wakes up
when I when I know she's awake in the
morning it's cuz I hear a beep beep
because she's taking your temperature to
see if she's fertile Wow I don't
understand what it means all of a sudden
you started doing it just like
everything else must be some magic yeah
she just does starts doing some new
thing she's like literally like a like
episodes of the sitcom because every
episode that could be like oh like the
pregnancy test or like the next episode
is moon rocks never a dull moment no
it's not it's the tomato errors she's
the Joe of your life oh you don't want
me yeah you and Jess can relate then
yeah for sure yeah yeah Jess is the
weird one hmm she doesn't sleep with the
dogs in the bed pretty sanitary dude
it's pretty good
I rather cuddle I do oh but wait I want
a big family cuddle sometimes though she
does let them on and I say I see you
breaking the rule she goes just this
time on top of the blankets
she's considerate of your wanting that
big yeah cuz we'll do a four-way cuddle
so the dogs will be like here and then
I'll [ __ ] pile them all up and I hug
them all at once that's awesome
[Music]